we thank all of you for your patience on
this late Saturday afternoon
we hope the panel that about to be
presented will give truth to the
proposition that the last is the best
this panel was formed to outline Asian
American contributions to American
society many speakers over the last two
days have referred in various ways to
the historical presidents of Asian
Americans and particularly Chinese
Americans and their contributions our
children obviously learn in their
history classes about the contributions
made in such industries as mining in the
railroads and the agriculture by the
first generation of immigrants but as
annastolz comments a moment ago outlined
we have an enormous reservoir of talent
among the Chinese American community
today each generation of immigrants and
the children of those immigrants faces
unique challenges unique risks unique
opportunities I think it is worthwhile
mentioning that in the postwar years the
generation of the so-called
chinese-american baby boomers the
generation of Chinese parents then had
limited confidence in general in their
own English communication skills and a
high anxiety about the state of race
relations and racial discrimination in
America and an abiding faith in the
power of education particularly in
science and technology and in medicine
as a consequence those Chinese Americans
who came of age in the 1970s and 1980s
tended in disproportionate numbers to
enter the fields of science engineering
and medicine and to study in those
fields at least as undergraduates but
times have changed and America has
changed today many of us have access to
much better education in communications
the barriers of racial discrimination
have come down very significantly and
there are multiple paths now open to
success in this American society science
medicine and engineering are certainly
still respected but it is no longer
perceived by
these Americans as the only path our
panel today reflects and celebrates the
diversity of paths to success and paths
for contribution to American society and
we have deliberately chosen I think a
very diverse group representing the
media and motion pictures corporate
finance medical research and history and
journalism among others I will introduce
briefly the entire panel and then turn
it over to Eric view who will moderate
the panel for us today I will not
embarrass either the speakers or myself
by trying to recite the many
accomplishments of this distinguished
group their full biographies are in your
program materials let me begin with
Oscar Tang who was to my immediate left
he is a member of the committee of 100
and a co-founder of the committee of 100
I think it is fair to characterize Oscar
is one of Wall Street's most successful
financial professionals now a director
of invest formerly known as New England
investment companies with over a hundred
and thirty billion dollars under
investment prior to that he was the
co-founder president and CEO of rice and
tang and outstanding investment advisory
firm he is a member of numerous
corporate boards and nonprofit boards
including koa holdings and the
Metropolitan Museum as well as his alma
mater the Phillips Academy for those of
you who are parents and anxious to prime
your children towards school he is a
graduate of Yale and the Harvard
Business School Eric Liu was next in
line and further down is an author and
journalist he is currently a contributor
to MSNBC and a writer for slate magazine
he is an author of the best-selling
accidental Asian which is an
extraordinary collection of essays on
the development of racial consciousness
and racial identity in modern America he
has held numerous positions in
Washington as well having served as a
former speechwriter for President
Clinton director of legislative affairs
at the National Security Council and as
a legislative assistant to Senator David
born he is a graduate of Yale as well
next we have Janet yang who is also a
member of the committee of 100 she and
her partner Lisa Henson are now the
owners of the Manifest film company
which is one of Hollywood's outstanding
production companies they've already
produced two films Savior which is
highly topical in light of our conflict
in Kosovo currently starring Dennis
Quaid and it was the co-producer of zero
effect from 1989 to 96 she was president
of X lon
Oliver Stone's film production company
where she handled all film for
development and production and she was
especially recognized for her production
of People vs Larry Flynt prior to those
positions she had an extensive career in
both television and film always linked
always linked by careful and considered
connections between Hollywood and China
which probably reflects the fact that
she has a BA from Brown University in
Chinese Studies as well as an MBA from
Columbia iris Chang is next in line on
the panel she is a member of the
committee of 100 and is really one of
the country's now rising stars in
history and and popular history in
particular she has two books to her
credit threat of the silkworm and the
New York Times bestseller rape of
Nanjing which she has almost pioneered
single-handedly and bringing to light
the atrocities committed by Japanese
troops in China and during the Second
World War
she is a recipient of the MacArthur
Foundation Award and she is currently
working on a narrative history of
Chinese in America she has her BA from
the University of Illinois and has done
graduate work at Johns Hopkins
University
finally to show that we are not giving
up on science medicine and technology
altogether we have dr. David Hall also a
member of the committee of 100 he is
currently the CEO and scientific
director for the Aaron Diamond AIDS
Research Center in New York and also I
believe concurrently a professor of
medicine at Rockefeller
he is widely acknowledged as one of the
world's foremost medical researchers on
aids including the genetic basis of HIV
and HIV replication he is a recipient of
the Ernst Young Award in medicine he has
been named by Time magazine as Man of
the Year in 1996 and has been elected to
the prestigious Institute of Medicine at
the National Academies of science
prior to this set of honors he was also
involved in clinical and research
positions at the Harvard Medical School
UCLA and NYU he is currently serving as
a member of the board of trustees at his
alma mater Cal Tech and also at the
Harvard Board of Overseers he received
his BS summa [ __ ] laude in physics from
Caltech and his md degree from the
Harvard Medical School I hope I've kept
within carolyn's instructions for a
rapid introduction and Eric I turn it
over to you thank you
thank you very much and we will perhaps
and hopefully be joined as well by David
Henry Hwang and will leave a seat for
him at the table I'm just gonna offer a
couple of introductory remarks about the
the topic that we all are going to
discuss and converse about today and
really then try to open it up to
conversation among the panelists and
ultimately to conversation hopefully
among all of us here who are gathered
today we've come here today I think get
a just a fascinating time in talking and
thinking about the place that Chinese
Americans occupy in this country's life
and in this country's imagination and I
think that we're gathered at a time when
Asian Americans and Chinese Americans in
particular are getting more active than
ever and more present than ever in every
walk in every realm of American life
from the arts to business to politics to
history to the sciences what have you
you cannot turn a page in the newspaper
now you cannot read your own trade
journal whatever profession you might be
in without encountering names and faces
and voices of Asian Americans and
Chinese Americans and so I think that
unquestionably the influence of Asian
Americans in this country in every realm
of life in this country is on the rise
in this panel really does testify to
that this extraordinary panel before we
go any farther I just want to indulge
myself this is moderators prerogative
and once again applaud our panel for
being here today
at the same time that the influence of
asian-americans is certainly on the rise
what we've seen as well is a sense in
which this idea of Asian influence this
idea of Asian contributions Asian
involvement has brought a a certain
darker aspect as well in the way that
non Asians tend to talk about Asian
Americans and we've seen that over these
last few years alone whether it was in
the context of the campaign finance
scandals where Asian money kind of fear
inspector of Asian money was was
inflated in many regards we're seeing it
now in these allegations of espionage
questions of loyalty we see it even in
the realm I think of higher education
where Asian Americans have made perhaps
their most visible mark and on many
campuses questions as to whether there
are too many Asians whether there's too
much Asian influence whether there's a
presence and influence out of proportion
and so I think as I say this is just a
fascinating time for us to be thinking
about these questions of contributions
of Asian American contributions to
American society I think it's just a
critical time right now to explore the
full breadth and the full meaning of
what that contribution is as I say on an
individual level as our panelists
testified to there are countless
asian-americans who are making a huge
difference in changing our culture in
our society but I think perhaps one of
the greatest and more profound
contributions at Asian Americans and
Chinese Americans in particular are
making is one - the very idea of what it
means to be American it's not so much
about what's happening in this field or
that profession it's not so much about
what individual accomplishments we might
be able to rack up but I think what
Chinese Americans are doing just by
virtue of getting in more more involved
in every realm of American life is to
add a much needed degree of complexity
to all the conversations that go on in
this country about race and identity and
about that most fundamental question
that comes up time and again which is
who is us
who is us and so I think that one of the
things that this panel does apart from
their individual accomplishments is
embody that spirit embody that spirit of
really trying to push the boundaries of
what it means to be an American push the
boundaries and the understandings of
people of every background so that
people's expectations people's ideas of
what's right and proper for Asian
Americans and Chinese Americans to be
doing are opened and expanded as well so
that somebody could walk into this room
this afternoon or see a tape of this
event later on today and we could reach
that point through the actions of these
people and others where they will see a
room like this and think first think
without thinking there is a room full of
Americans I think that is the
contribution that these people are
ultimately pushing us toward and I think
that all of them in their own respective
ways are pioneers and really people who
have been giving voice I think that's
the common theme and thread that really
runs through the work and the
accomplishments of all of them and I'd
like to really begin the conversation
among the panelists on this question of
voice and role and place and space and
I'd like to pose the question and all of
you can take a take a stab at this just
I'd like to know and I think it would be
of great interest to the people who are
involved here today in your own walk of
life in your own field what kinds of
challenges and obstacles that a
asian-americans face what kinds of
obstacles have you faced as an
asian-american and what kinds of things
have you felt like you've had to do or
want it to do to negotiate and navigate
those kinds of obstacles whether they're
professional whether they're cultural
whatever they may be so that as you've
been these pioneers in your vert in your
various fields you can perhaps shed some
light to the many others who are here
today and and who are listening to what
you have to say and why don't we start
Janet with you I know that when we spoke
earlier we were talking about the theme
of role models and Janet is no doubt a
role model to many many people Asian or
not women or not but particularly
asian-american
who are thinking about Hollywood and the
media and I and when I asked her about
that I asked her well who had been her
role models and Janet wanna you tell us
what what you had to say about that well
to answer the first part of your
question I think growing up I was very
much a part of a victim I suppose of a
perception of Asian Americans that has
certainly been contradicted by this
conference Asian Americans or Chinese
Americans are shy no we are not we are
trial if you heard charles long last
night you know he's we're very funny we
are quiet no we're not we're very verbal
very verbose in fact we are somehow
retiring we are know if you see Wylie
I'll perform he's brash and expressive
if you heard Anna Chennault you would
say no we're not even modest we are
we're out there but this is not what
people think of us somehow there's a
huge discrepancy between the reality
that exists today and what people
perceive though of us as being and I
think this has a lot to do with the
images that are on the big screen and
the little screen I know for myself
growing up there virtually existed
nothing in the way of interesting roles
for Asians and I think it wasn't until I
lived in China in the early 80s that I
myself was struck by this and I thought
my god here I'm living in a country
where Chinese faces occupy every every
walk of life on the screen they are of
all different personalities as the
diversity group as the one can imagine
and yet these were not representing the
West and so it was really China and and
the Chinese movies initially and
bringing Chinese movies the United
States and eventually putting Chinese
and Asian faces and Asian themed themes
on the screen that motivated me to get
into the movie business I did not fancy
myself as a Hollywood producer at all
but it was it was tough going because
back then in the 80s there we were
fighting a lot of stereotypes and and I
really didn't have a role model tants
the second part of your question it was
there simply wasn't a path that existed
that I could sort of emulate I was
following my nose I had a passion to do
something I had no idea what was leading
to and I don't think one could chart
sort of a progression in a very logical
fashion but I am now more committed than
ever to the idea of building a bridge
through film and television and knowing
that this is really a language that
speaks to people around the world I
think so much of what you said I think
applies to just about everybody here and
I'm curious iris
these same questions about not
necessarily having a clear path set out
for you or these kind of role models I
mean the kind of work that you've done
in bringing so much historical you know
significant historical material to the
light into the consciousness not only of
Chinese Americans but again to everybody
in this country did you feel like as you
set out to do that that you were really
on your own in a sense what kind of
models were you following as you decided
that you wanted to do this and you know
it goes to what Janet said you know
these stereotypes about Asian Americans
not wanting to express their voice I
can't think of somebody anybody more
than iris who's really gone out there
and made her voice heard thank you I I
and I can't agree more I think that the
stereotype of the Chinese not having a
voice not really wanting a voice is
completely false
there were many Chinese Americans when I
was growing up who wanted to be writers
unfortunately there weren't role models
I knew of no chinese-american authors at
the time when I was growing up who I
could look towards as somebody could
Emily so I found role models but they
had to be people who were not
necessarily asian-americans I was not
only concerned when I was growing up
about the absence of role models in
literature in American literature but
also the absence of Chinese Americans in
the whole realm of US history
my third book is going to be a narrative
history of the Chinese in America
and what alarms me is that many
historians tell me the last 50 years of
Chinese American accomplishment is is
practically not existent at all the
historical literature and just being at
this conference from the last few days
has made me realize that this is a you
know a serious problem because I see so
many leaders at this conference in the
sciences and business and the arts in so
many different fields and yet it has
been almost completely neglected by the
historical community but I think it is a
responsibility that we have as Chinese
Americans and as chinese-american
leaders to make ourselves heard
documents that you have press clippings
you know any kind of sense of
accomplishment should be recorded and
made available to historians I also
became aware when I was growing up that
there was very little information often
about Chinese history in general for
example the my second book The Rape of
Nanking describes one of the worst
atrocities of world history how more
than 300,000 Chinese were brutally
slaughtered and raped in the capital of
China 60 years ago now I learned about
this only because my parents told me
about the Nanking Massacre when I was a
little girl but I was shocked when I
went into the school libraries and all
the public libraries in my hometown I
could not find a word on the subject in
English furthermore my my school
teachers had no clue as to what I was
talking about and so I think it is the
responsibility of Chinese Americans to
make sure that this is documented that
these stories are told and passed on to
the next generation because if we don't
do it I don't think anyone else is going
to do it for us well I RC the there's no
question that you've been doing it and I
think that everybody here in this room
would be grateful for what you've been
in doing and I think the
the question you raised the theme of
arrays of responsibilities is one that I
think runs throughout this whole kind of
dialogue and and David you know I'm just
wondering I think that certainly in the
work that you've been doing which is so
centrally important and in so many ways
so bound up with social issues and a
sense of social and moral responsibility
I'm wondering just you know as you've
gone about that work what kinds of when
you even set out on doing that kind of
work again
to start out with the initial question
what sense of obstacles did you feel
like you faced or that you see today
other Asian Americans facing in your
field which is the field we're still so
many of the brightest and most able
Asian Americans are heading toward and
what sense of responsibility does that
raise in your mind well perhaps some I'm
the only stereotypic asian-american here
on the panel
I hope I'm not on the panel because I
got good grades in school and he's aced
the SAT and went to MIT Caltech and to
boot got in a doctorate degree from
Harvard I think I hope I'm here because
everybody's parents are proud on your
parents behalf I must say my proud as
well but but like rest of the panelists
here I pursue my passion and I think I
worked hard and and did it well and and
hopefully that work is now making a
difference as with respect to the
question asked about what's agen
scientists face in this country what are
the obstacles obviously you know that
asian-americans among the very best in
science many are doing our standing work
I would say contributed substantially to
put America first in science but if he
if you look at the very top of academia
particularly in sciences and biomedical
feel asian-americans underrepresented
and I often ask why that is and and
thought about my own role in that
context and I think there are there are
some reasons for that I think it was
said earlier that perhaps Asians are
quieter and people are asked to be more
modest while that may not be entirely
true for this panel is certainly is
quite true for many who chose to the
sciences were right and wrong are
clear-cut whereas in other fields right
and wrong tend to be more subjective and
so there's actually a seating that's
self-imposed or imposed by by our
culture and in addition for many Asian
American scientists in this country
there's the further problem of a slight
language gap were not as articulate in
English as those who were born here and
and I want to here emphasize a point
that Charles Wang brought up yesterday
and that is the that is what what is
happening to a large number of Asian
American scientists is that they do the
work well but they can't present the
work in an articulate manner and and
thus these individuals doomed to be
technicians as he put it and I certainly
see that in my father's generation my
own generation and now as I look to my
younger colleagues that is certainly
true
but there is also another factor and
that is the the unwilling unwillingness
to take leadership roles there's
something about those who went into
science they say leadership that
involves politics and somehow that's
dirty I certainly don't feel that way
but there is a strong sentiment in that
regard and also leadership means making
decisions and decisions means at times
you have to take risks and I think
that's why our Chinese are known for
their risk-taking in business and then
certainly in Las Vegas it's it's not a
common practice in science and so so
there's a there's an excessive avoidance
of risk and as hello Shapiro from
Princeton put it so nicely that is wrong
and that is an application of leadership
and acceptance of mediocrity and so I
think in my own career in science I
diverted from the stereotype a bit in in
that I was a willing to take certain
positions on science policy and also at
least in my small capacity as the leader
of a small Research Institute run the
Institute and also speak out on the
national level and and lately I've been
given the platform and you bring up
responsibility with any recognition that
I've gotten that comes with
responsibility and my responsibilities
is is number one to speak about what I
do and and how enormous this epidemic is
that that we face and in the problem
aids I was very pleased that Jim
Wolfensohn lunch mentioned just a few of
the statistics it's an enormous problem
that threatens our entire
and and I take that as my responsibility
and use my you know recent recognition
to speak on that particularly issue and
at the same time I also use that
platform to speak as an asian-american
on on issues of concern to our community
well you you speak in particular about
these questions of leadership and and
getting your voice out there in a
question of risk and risk aversion I
don't know what Oscars Las Vegas
activities are but I certainly know that
in the realm of business he's he must
have accepted a certain high tolerance
for risk because he's had a great degree
of success and Oscar we'd just like to
hear a little bit of think on those same
themes and questions do you feel like
the business world the business
environment is one which has less or
more or just a different kind of
obstacles for Asian and Chinese
Americans well perhaps I could first go
back a little bit and and iris mentioned
the issue of history I guess first of
all I'm at least half a generation older
than my fellow panelists here and
perhaps have a little bit of different
background in the sense that I came here
at a young age with which many David I
know also came at the age of 12 but I
came and in 1949 at the age of 11 and
was totally immersed into a American
local really in Vermont in a small town
in Vermont so I had to if you will learn
to live with in a totally American
environment and I think the history that
I'm referring to is that as a child as a
student in China I
learn two things which is that I was
sort of always taught that in Chinese
that gave me tremendous reservoir of of
cultural background and that I had the
potential to be like many Chinese if you
will the potential to really excel in
many ways I don't know if I had that
capability or not but I was sort of
taught that number one that Chinese had
somehow a strength and the superior
culture of belief in education in family
support that was one part of it then
even in fourth and fifth grade you read
the history about China especially the
last hundred fifty years of China's
history and and you learn as a child
that something was wrong that that
China's history if you will that having
this distinguished past somehow things
hadn't gone very well
and in fact I lived in the French sector
of Shanghai just imagine that what that
meant if you are a Chinese person and
you lived in by the time I was going
around I guess these science didn't
exist but I was told that there were
clubs around in the French sector that
had signs that said you know no Chinese
or dogs allowed so I had a sort of a
mixed message and I came into an
environment here and I should tell you I
came in luckily - primarily an
educational environment really schools
and colleges and so forth so they were
really very very tolerant but there were
no virtually no other Chinese in these
communities at that point a few perhaps
nothing like it is now so I guess I had
to learn
to operate it just as an individual I
didn't particularly think in terms of
being a Chinese person and what were you
and that's really the the so it was less
a lack of a there was no role model if
you will but perhaps the strength that
came from knowing the fact that I come
from this culture and this really rich
past and that that that should have
given me the potential to to if I worked
at it that perhaps I could succeed so
that's really the the the way I've
looked at it I think that in speaking
about some of the characteristics I
think that I should also mention that I
operated in in environment which tended
to be more entrepreneurial in other
words for whatever reason I chose not to
go into a let's say a large structured
business type of environment I think
Wall Street tends to operate more on at
least I felt on ideas and going back to
what David was saying you have to
believe in the power of your ideas and
if you believe in the power of the ideas
I think that you have to be able to
present them you have to articulate them
and convince other people that these
ideas have merit and that we should all
pursue them whether it be in scientific
areas or in business areas and then you
have to be willing to act on them and
that's the risk-taking element which is
that that you have to put your
reputation your your career what will
you to explain them and then
to to lead an organization to act on
that and to take the risk of being wrong
if you will in that process so I think
that is the element of risk taking which
is I think a very important part I might
also mention that we shouldn't make too
much of the limitations we should really
celebrate the opportunities if you look
at the educational background of this
panel you cannot say that the
opportunities are not available to us I
mean the educationally it is open to us
it I have always felt this and so it's
more important to me.they that we
participate that we strike out and we
assume that we're going to be treated
fairly sometimes you may not be but if
you start with the idea that you're not
going to be treated fairly you're not
gonna adventure out if you don't venture
out you're never gonna have the chance
for your own talents to be to be used if
you will well I think that's absolutely
right and among the many points that you
bring out is this whole question which
you know I think everybody here can
speak to about following a structure
network first is striking out on your
own and I think certainly you know I'd
love to hear Janet I mean what do you
think about that and the kind of
challenges in Hollywood I mean I think
that in one sense can define the very
split of what Hollywood is about and and
how you've tried to figure out which way
to go and that in that choice and how
others have well I'll tell you a funny
story I was battling among other things
my parents aren't prejudiced about the
arts in general as you all probably know
in Confucian society it's sort of the
bottom of the totem pole to want to work
in the arts the film certainly or
anything of that nature so they were
quite concerned and they were doubly
concerned
when I became very interested in
studying Chinese history and language
and literature although they wanted to
raise me as a good Chinese girl growing
up and wanted me to go to Saturday
school and study Chinese when I became
actually serious about it later in life
they started to panic because they
thought well what are you going to do
with that
and when I went to live in China they
considered that really extreme and none
of these pieces were fitting together
when I became interested in a film then
they just became apoplectic I mean what
was this all going to mount to so there
was that constant not knowing where it
was going I mean again this was a time
where people weren't paying much
attention to China on a on a political
level particularly much less on a
cultural level and where I really again
had no structure whatsoever to follow I
at a certain point I was approached by
Steven Spielberg to work with him on his
film and part of the Sun in China which
was purely because I had been traveling
back and forth to China and I was simply
the only person in Hollywood that you
know could speak Chinese and actually
near the Chinese film industry and was
working on a studio and that was a name
that kind of got them interested a
little bit when I weren't to work at MCA
Universal and I was able to present them
with the you know company profile and
the fact that I had 17,000 employees
that got them kind of excited you know I
might get stock office and all that but
it wasn't until I was in that structure
did it suddenly seem like a legitimate
job to them after that I want to join
Oliver Stone and once again their faces
bells that well who's Oliver Stone and
how many people going to be in that
company and we had a little office on
the beach in Venice and again they
couldn't understand they follow my sort
of rollercoaster path and really the the
industry in many ways especially from my
end of it it tends to be a bit gypsy
like we're a bunch of vagabonds we have
if we're lucky we get our overhead paid
for but really we're living from project
to project and there's a lot of dead
time in between and we are constantly in
a state of flux if not risk
so I think it takes it does take courage
I suppose first for some poor to feel
like oh there isn't this institutional
kind of backing you know to what to what
we do and and it and I think that when
at some of the censorship that we all
face is this kind of self-censorship can
we do it do we have the courage to to
proceed is this gonna be okay you know
what happens if we fail there's such a
high bar placed on the children of
Chinese parents my experiences and and
and isn't is it if we don't get much
encouragement from them and they have
very odd ways of sort of measuring our
success and I think that the only thing
that makes them feel at ease now is that
they know that I have made you know good
income on certain movies and so they
feel okay I'm secure because ultimately
what they want is a feeling that we will
be ok we can raise our children and you
know not be thrown out on the street but
it's it's a state of mind as well it's a
it's a entrepreneur like that the
industry is going from some major
fluctuations right now it is very
unstable even the big institutions like
a universal in fact is practically on
the point of bankruptcy at this point
it's not able it's been telling its
producers on the lot and ITT expensive
restaurants and you can imagine how that
sits with these producers which is you
know often considered producer often
considered have a life of extravagance
so it's it's you know it's one that
causes you one is forced to be kind of a
little bit ahead of the curve on the
cutting edge and figure out what is
going on you can't ever really get
comfortable so I personally I maybe one
day I'll go back to working at a studio
I'm not sure if that will be the case or
not but there is mmm nothing's for
certain and your your career depends a
lot on your last film and there's so
many highs and lows and as a basic
business investment it's risky it is
very very high-risk something like one
in ten films actually makes money and
you know if you can getting a film done
any film is extremely difficult so
you're kind of you're always living on
the edge a little bit and for me I think
I'd like that it sort of keeps me on the
edge and keeps me Frenchy you get fresh
you can't really get complacent but it's
very very not Confucian it's very and I
think one of the challenges that Asian
Americans Chinese Americans face is how
to take the best of those Confucian
values and and not kind of blindly
superimpose them on our society they
don't really apply and the things that
work better in America are innovation
and you know you don't
as we joked about lesson you don't need
the degrees in fact Hollywood if
anything is it's more of a meritocracy
than just about any other place I can
think of because people really don't
care if you've ever done anything before
it's what can you do now they don't care
who your father is they don't care if
you've had their degrees none of this
matters I mean I think I was probably
prepared for Hollywood you know in
certain ways because I grew up in a
Jewish neighborhood I happen to go to an
all-boys prep school Phillips Exeter
Academy and now Phillips Academy and
maybe this was some preparation but
ultimately you know I was doing it by
the seat of my pants and and that's how
it will probably continue to be forever
well I think everybody here can identify
with that whole question of culture and
values and the values that our families
and our parents immerse us in and
whether and how those values influence
our own choices about the ways that we
go about doing things I mean one word
that you said when you were saying and I
looked immediately to Iris was the word
self-censorship because I think there
certainly in taking undertaking a
project like The Rape of Nanking there
would be all kinds of pressure whether
coming from self or from outside to
censor and to keep the voice down and
not to make a stink and that its
inherent I think in the nature of the
project but I think a lot of that is
inherent to in the kind of values and
cultural behaviors that a lot of us have
been so steeped in and I wonder if you
could just tell a little bit about those
tensions
well I think that in order to be an
author you have to be independent line
and very very strong because as an
author you don't have any infrastructure
unless you become a writer in residence
at a university but if you leave the
protection let's say oh can you hear me
yeah if you leave the protection of the
newspaper the magazine the university
you're really on and I have to say that
being an author is one of the most
intellectually liberating career I've
ever undertaken but it's also the
riskiest and I guess I was very
fortunate in that my parents were always
very supportive of my my career I like
many Asian parents they stressed
education and hard work right from the
beginning including you know you know
literature or literary pursuits I think
unlike many parents though they were
intensely idealistic I grew up in a very
academic town I grew up in the
university town of Champaign Urbana
Illinois and there was a sense I think
in that community that that the quest
for beauty and truth was really a more
noble calling than the pursuit of money
this could be because most people in
Champaign Urbana weren't making that
much money but on the other hand there
was the sense that we were above you
know money we were above politics it
wasn't just my parents I think this was
kind of a sense that we had in that
whole town so in my family in particular
I think we were really encouraged to
question authority to not only question
Authority the question the prevailing
wisdom of the era to ask questions
and to not be afraid to think on your
own and it was considered really one of
the highest honors to add to the body of
human knowledge I in fact I remember
even my father was very critical
something that Confucius had said he
once said you know Confucius said that a
woman's highest virtue is her ignorance
he said that's just ridiculous and so I
think my parents were in a certain way
they were steeped in Asian values but
they were also very progressive and very
liberal minded and so there was a sense
that you just don't tailor your beliefs
to fit this season's political fashion
so you think on your own you've got to
believe and you that you can make a
difference and so I think that it was it
was this sense that I had which which we
were also cultivated to believe that
this was also a very Chinese belief you
know that scholars are well respected in
China and and you know they especially
the the you know the literary types that
the philosophers that this was something
that was a noble calling and I think
that's really what sustained me
throughout throughout my career but I
think you're you're absolutely right you
have to be very you have to be very
strong because it's a solitary
profession and when you write a book you
are constantly subject to scrutiny and
criticism but in the end I think it's
that it's the richest life that you can
have and the important thing I think is
to realize that in this country in in
the United States and you really can't
starve even it would take I think a lot
of a lot of effort to starve to death
and and you really do have a benefit of
a free press in this country which is
not necessarily something that you have
in other countries
but the the publisher in Japan for
example that had wanted to translate my
book The Rape of Nanking because you
know he's they've received threats and
so it's it's not something I think that
you really can take for granted in this
country and so I I really do believe
that one of the reasons why you know the
many Chinese parents discourage their
children from going into I think
literature or filmmaking or anything
unconventional I don't think it comes
from a fundamental disrespect because I
think a lot of them do realize the
importance of the Arts I do think that
it's it's this fear of going into what
is political you see I think this is
historically rooted in in their own
backgrounds that there's a good
historical reason for this most of the
parents of my generation and most of the
parents of my my friends and and people
who were of my parents his generation
had to flee China I in in 1949 to escape
communism and they really lived in fear
of you know often persecution and I
think there was the sense that all of
them had gotten burned because they had
gone into politics
and and so my parents told me you know
when they were growing up in Taiwan
their parents and other parents were
saying to their children to not go into
politics and they were encouraged to go
into the sciences because the future lay
in the United States where you could
become successful and also secure by
remaining apolitical and I think that
kind of fear of speaking out of taking a
leadership role of becoming political
that that has actually still it's it's
it's gone from one generation to the
next and I think it's it's not so much
that the Chinese aren't willing to take
leadership positions I think it is
rooted in
and basically the fear of what can
happen if you lose out in a political
battle because I mean in this country if
you lose an election you you know you
lose an election that I think in this in
another country if you lose out on the
political game you could lose your life
political so I'm it's it's Nokes you
know it's no trivial matter so I think
this is one reason why people often feel
held back from having from speaking out
when they really should well I think
it's just fascinating what you say I
mean one of the the and what you say I
think applies not only to the realm of
politics strictly as politics or even
writing or even journalism but I think
one of the most important lessons that
this generation of Chinese Americans may
have to offer to to our parents and to
our contemporaries is just that no
matter what walk of life you're in and I
think David certainly can attest to this
that you can find ways to step into the
public square
that doesn't mean running for office
necessarily doesn't mean you know
writing a polemical you know article or
anything like that but I think that what
it does mean is just getting into the
habits all of us of being able to step
into the public square and David I'm
just wondering how it was you know to
the great degree that you've done that
how it was that you came to those habits
were those habits that you stumbled upon
were those habits that others cultivated
in you that sense that I wasn't just
gonna stay and do my thing but I was
gonna do my thing and a think about the
wider consequences of it and be speak to
the wider society about it I mean what
was it that gave you that sense of
capacity I'm not sure there was one
single thing I pursue what I did I
pursue research on viruses particularly
on the AIDS virus
built by projects build my program and
and and the Institute and gradually as
you get into the science and establish
yourself
you you have to get involved in that in
the sense that there is a National AIDS
policy and if you're a significant
player you have to have some sort of
opinion and you can't just hold back and
say I'm a scientist might have no
opinion on controversial issues
concerning condom distribution
concerning needle exchange or the the
inequities between us and the developing
countries I think you have to get into
the fray once you're in reading into the
field so it was a gradual process I
would say particularly as I assume the
leadership of the Arin diamond aids
Research Center and particularly as it
gained prominence in the field
everybody wanted your opinion and one
had to make the decision at that point
should I stay a pure scientist and
pureeing quotations or get into dirty
politics at times and and I could still
recall a few years ago at the age of 40
trying to criticize the National
Institute of Health with respect to its
distribution of money for AIDS research
it was clear that the emphasis was not
proper and by clearly stating so in 1992
offended a lot of people but I think I
was in the in the right position and at
that point it I could see the people
even though they they hear scientific
presentations from Chinese American
frequently they don't generally hear
comments on policy issues from Chinese
American scientists and and I could
still recall Institute directors and
directors of the National Institute of
Health saying who is this guy but I
think that's how I gradually
got into this process and and realized
it is a responsibility what I do is
funded by public money largely and and
it is my responsibility to to tell the
public what I do and also to express my
opinion on how certain things should
proceed well I'm wondering whether any
of the panelists just have thoughts I
wanted that the word responsibility has
come up time and time again in this
conversation I'm wondering if anybody
wants to just tackle the the question
concretely of how those of us who are in
leadership positions can actually
discharge that responsibility I mean in
your particular walk of life what is it
that you think you could do or that you
are already doing to know you know
number one set an example and lead by
example but number two to build concrete
bridges and connections to other parts
of American society and also to the next
generation of Chinese Americans and then
you know as Jim Wolfensohn was saying to
the next generation of people who will
be coming to events like this one within
your given the fields and in it you know
anyone if you have any thoughts in this
I think it'd be very valuable to talk
concretely about the things that we we
all of us in this room can be doing to
build those kind of bridging connections
well I think one thing that I think it's
important to recognize that we are
Chinese but it's also important to
recognize that we live in America and
that by and large you're gonna succeed
in an American environment I think we
talk a lot about things like the glass
ceiling and I'm certain that these
things exist but more and more the
society is becoming more open in even in
say an area such as the capital markets
and enterprise business enterprises
large established companies and such
structures in in turmoil as newer forces
come along and the new forces can become
very major very quickly and the capital
markets are getting more and more open
to finance these new enterprises new
ideas so that what you're dealing with
is is a society if you will which is
very much coming our way so again we
should focus on that side as opposed to
the limitations which granted do exist
don't focus so much on the glass
ceilings focus really on the
opportunities because they're coming our
way and I think it's important that
while we keep our roots if you will
understand where we come from the
society that we come from and support
organizations such as the committee of
100 or other institutions that that
promote Chinese culture
Chinese values or Chinese heritage if
you will it's also important to I think
be really part of mainstream America
after all the institutions here going to
be primarily American and and you know
they do give us the great opportunities
that we have and it's important that we
we return that in some way and to me one
of the things is is is you know so it's
important to play a civic role in our
society and to return something to that
society in the general terms so my
feeling is that you know I have to do
both
in other words that to return something
both to the chinese-american our own
identity the art and the cultural
institutions which I think have been so
enriching for all of us to help educate
Americans about Chinese art and culture
background history what will you but
it's also important to play a central
role in the central institutions to
become America if you were to become
part American in that process so whether
it be in civic activities or in
philanthropy I think it's important that
we participate in it
I feel like I'm in a position where I'm
very much part of mainstream America or
delivering product to mainstream America
but I'm also in a position where I could
be serving the community better by
making films like The Joy Luck Club I'd
like to make another film like that
however as a community we're not we
don't yet really back the arts we get a
lot of finger-pointing we get a lot of
this doesn't look good we don't like
this role we don't like that movie and
frankly it scares people off and there
isn't enough support coming from our own
community for films that are made or
could be made and primarily this would
come in the form of financial backing if
people want to see movies about
ourselves on the screen we probably have
to go much further in financing those
films because for the time being we are
still battling the stereotypes and there
is no real motivation especially with a
lot of this kind of finger-pointing for
the people who currently write the
checks to say oh let's take a gamble and
and make this film that has some Asian
content or some you know some other
seemingly political content that serves
the Asian community it just is not
likely to happen it happens almost by
accident with in the case of The Joy
Luck Club it happened to be a
best-selling book it's not a film again
that one could easily go out and
convince other people to do although it
did well it was an all Asian cast an
all-female cast we haven't seen many of
those happen yet so we need to work
together more to figure out what is or
how can we do how can we share in each
other's resources and how can how can we
join hands better and how can we
encourage our children to become good
screenwriters because it's it's much
easier to criticize than it is to create
we need great screenplays with stories
that would be appealing and accessible
to American audiences as well as
international audiences and Asian
American audiences that are written
maybe by Chinese Americans or Asian
Americans but they need to be encouraged
to do so there needs to be some
incentive and we need we need to
get up you know we there's there's you
know in a room like this
there are ways in which we could
actually do that but we haven't actually
done it yet so we we could we could be
going a lot further and it's it's a it's
a battle every day that any producer
faces getting somebody to write a check
for your movie it's so many pieces have
to become a line the Stars have to come
together any number of things that you
know that are a seemingly impossible
need to happen and it's and every film
eight is a minor miracle but there's a
way in which we could be more proactive
so I I would encourage people to think
along those lines and I'm here to
receive any funding if anybody wants to
well I really couldn't agree with Oscar
and Janet more I really think you're
gonna have to assume that you'll succeed
and not really shoot yourself down
before someone else has had a chance to
try that and as Chinese Americans I
think we really need to mentor each
other we're going to have to support
each other and you know speak up for
each other I think there should be a lot
more effort to you know publish our own
experiences or support artistic works
such as films or books on the Asian
American or Chinese American experience
because in the end it is money that
determines whether these things get made
and the book publishing industry is very
similar to Hollywood in that in the end
the bottom line is what really counts
and executives always look to see how a
previous project has done before
deciding whether to fund another project
that has a similar theme so if they get
the sense that a community an ethnic
community is not supporting its own
projects they are much less likely to
gamble on a similar topic and
like Janet you know I I to hear a lot of
complaints about people saying well you
know I don't like novels that are are
you know written about Chinese Americans
these days you know like sometimes the
characters are presented is weak you
know especially Chinese American men or
the women are seen as subservient and
and the truth is I think there are many
things that Chinese Americans can do in
order to shatter these stereotypes
first of all support the projects that
you feel give a more accurate depiction
of our community and secondly if your
children want to go into these fields if
they want to pursue their dreams don't
stand in their way
because we really need more voices in
American culture I think it's very
dangerous not to have a Chiney more of a
chinese-american presence and culture
and I think that the these stereotypes
can manifest out in our society in ways
that can harm all of us I'll just give
you a few examples I do think that to
this day and it was worse than the 1950s
the u.s. is still largely influenced by
this foo Manchu image of the evil
brilliant Chinese scientist but the
truth is Chinese American scientists
have really done more I think to help
American national defense than harm
they've helped build up Silicon Valley
you know they they have contributed
normos Li to fields such as aerospace
we've got you know Nobel laureates but
beyond that we also have thousands of
scientists who have men made enormous
contributions in just about every
scientific discipline there is
unfortunately if scientists in this
country are being suspected and
tarnished by these stereotypes that's
going to interfere with their work
and when I think of the you know the
alleged spying cases that are now at los
alamos I can't help but think of the
theme of my first book thread of the
silkworm which is the story of what
happened to a brilliant Chinese
scientist in the 1950s his name was dr.
2cn who shed he was the father of the
Chinese missile program and the reason
why he actually helped build up the
Chinese missile program was because when
he was in the United States as a
professor at Caltech and MIT and as you
know a founder of the Jet Propulsion
Laboratory he was falsely accused of
espionage and it eventually resulted in
his deportation to the People's Republic
of China where he then built up the
infrastructure of the ballistic missile
program in China and also contributed to
the I think design of the the silkworm
missile he initiated that project but
you see in at that time there was
rampant Chinese anti-chinese hysteria
and it was a time when Chinese people
could not live in certain neighborhoods
they they the the the movie depictions
of the Chinese were of the fu-manchu's
righty and he was a man who did not you
know they never were able to find any
concrete evidence that he was a spy
although we'll never know the full
details of this case but this the upshot
of the situation was that he was you
know arrested by I&S authorities he was
kind of tried and convicted in the
American press and things were just
blown out of proportion they said he was
trying to smuggle code books out of his
you know out of the country when the
code books turned out to be logarithmic
tables and you know and that set in
motion the events the ventually led to
his deportation but the the marathon
media at the time never you know tried
to correct that perception and when it
turned out that he really didn't smuggle
classified documents out of this country
they never corrected
and in the end this anti Chinese
hysteria this anti-communist hysteria
came back to haunt the United States
because we really lost one of the most
brilliant scientists in this country and
the country that was then that you know
the United States was very concerned
about the People's Republic of China
gained one so I think that that's why we
may look at the arcs of something as
esoteric and it's not really affects our
life but it actually does affect all of
us because it shapes public perception
of our community and that eventually is
going to translate into direct action
well that's a perfect segue to David you
know the question of well this larger
question in the first place that we
started with with the responsibilities
and the ways that we can make those
responsibilities concrete by building
bridges within the community and between
this community and others but in
particular I'd like to I'm curious to
hear you respond to this historical
allegory that iris talks about about the
way that this one individual Chinese
scientist had been treated in the past
in the midst of a lot of hysteria about
the influence of China and by extension
of Chinese Americans and I'm wondering
whether in your field which is broadly
speaking the sciences but is still so
far afield from all that's going on in
Los Alamos and the rest whether you're
feeling those kinds of ripple effects
the sense of politicization but the kind
of work you do and the kind of work that
others like in your position do oh
there's no question I feel the effect of
the most recent allegations first of all
I'm a chinese-american myself I also
came from Taiwan
I don't work with classified material I
work with the deadly vise but but more
importantly I actually have a number of
colleagues who are from mainland China
and they are greatly impacted by the
recent events they were impacted some
years ago when when there were
accusations that many Chinese
students spied for China and that was
not taken very well by the group and and
this is a even more serious charge and
and it's it's clear that it affects more
out they they are here contributing to
American science and for many years for
decades American science is largely
driven by the talent that flow from
other countries there was a period where
there was a great flow from from Europe
and of course in past several decades
there's been no tremendous flow from
Asia and particularly from China and an
America it's safe to say American
science would not be in his present form
without lots of and lots of foreign
talent and as iris just pointed out the
the contributions greatly outweigh any
espionage then should that be real and
and this need to be portrayed to the
public and it never does and so and as I
just to extend a little bit as I think
about how to carry our own work to to
international sites and particularly in
China some of my colleagues actually ask
whether we will be accused of selling
American science to foreign country for
example we're working hard trying to
develop a vaccine that might protect
against the most prevalent viruses now
circulating in China India and South
Africa and being the the leader of the
team and being a Chinese American I
always thought well perhaps it would be
easiest to conduct such a trial in China
do a collaboration get get it into early
testing in southern China with the
epidemic is will we face to a lesser
extent some of these accusations of
taking US dollars research funded by US
dollars and then and
benefiting quote the Chinese population
luckily for my biomedical sciences that
the view is is much more liberal and
then what it whatever is good for for us
passion is should be good for humanity
and then but there's no question that
that the recent events are a terrible
fall community well this um I think in
many ways brings us full circle I want
to leave the balance of our time the the
30 minutes or so that we have left to
take a lot of questions but I just want
to tie together a little bit what's been
said because I think you know what we're
left with and what we've heard a lot
from this panel today are these two
trends which coexist and run in many
ways parallel to one another intertwined
with one another and one is certainly a
trend toward more opportunity more
access more involvement and more
participation but perhaps not unrelated
to that rise in participation and
involvement and influence again is the
trend and perhaps it's to a lesser
degree but the trend in the sense that
there are still many in this country who
suspect the loyalties of Chinese
Americans or Asian Americans who
questioned or who come again as I said
at the outset to a room like this with a
presumption of foreignness with a
presumption that Asian Americans or
Chinese Americans are foreign until
proven otherwise
to me the benefit of the work that the
people on this panel are doing and the
benefit of the work that the committee
of 100 is doing is by word and deed to
begin to rebut that presumption and to
begin to shift the presumption so that
people come into a room like this and to
an environment like this and really
understand that the contributions that
people of Chinese descent are making and
the potential that people of Chinese
descent have in this country are
something to be reckoned with in a
positive way the realms that I've worked
in in politics and the media I think are
perhaps some of the most egregious in
terms of some of the stereotyping or the
absence of voice or what have you and I
think that this goes back as well to
what Janet and Oscar both have said
which is that it's
one thing to take a look at what's going
on out there and point out the flaws the
problems in opportunity the problems in
stereotyping but what is incumbent upon
all of us because we have the means and
the wherewithal to speak is to speak is
to get our voices out there and with
that I would really welcome some
comments or questions from this audience
to all of our panelists yes sir
I just won echo something iris said you
know about two weeks ago
you know our comedian 100 was invited by
the White House to have a session with
them another session the John Podesta
the chief of staff asked us to go dig up
some Chinese contribution specially in
the area of defense work and iris you'll
be happy to hear that that we had a good
missile builders intention but I also
have found that in the mid-80s 70% of
our tactical missiles was managed by a
brilliant Chinese engineer in Los
Angeles and his name happened to be
their walk so of course he's retired now
and I just want to bring to the
attention that we have good Chinese
American engineering engineers and
scientists work in the area of weapon
trees I can't agree more I mean that
really this but but scientists from
other foreign countries and that if if
there is a prevailing sense in our
country that all foreign-born scientists
are going to fall under suspicion that
would be devastating for our country and
that's why I think we just have to be
very careful you know I think nobody in
the committee of 100 would endorse
spying you know in any way shape or form
the question of course is our
foreign-born scientists being treated
differently when they are accused of
spying than people who are Caucasian or
who are who were born in this country so
I just think that that if people in this
country have a better sense of what the
contributions of these scientists have
been then I think that would really
dispel a lot of the suspicion which is
why again I think you know as David said
we really have to speak out
and I really do encourage you know
people who feel that they've made an
important scientific contribution it to
contact me via my publisher because I
think I need to know about it for my
third book and so does you know the rest
of the world really it's it's it's
really a gigantic void in the historical
literature yes over there
thanks for a wonderful discussion and I
also would like to thank y'all for sort
of presenting a very hopeful tone often
at a lot of Asian American conferences
that they all sort of have a tendency to
deteriorate into a bunch of sort of in
into these self-pitying sessions and so
I'd like to thank you for sort of
presenting to today's agent Americans
what what the possibilities are and I
like to thank mr. Oscar ting in
particular for sort of talking about the
fact that despite tremendous
difficulties like great strides have
been made my question is that when do
you all think that Chinese Americans
actually can actually laugh at
themselves I think one of the reasons
that the Jerome z-trip was so successful
was because precisely of his
self-deprecating sense of humor and I
think that for various other minorities
that sort of have made it for instance
you know if you look at the Jewish
minority group or various others that
there is an ability to laugh at oneself
and and I think it seems to me that
often for Chinese Americans whenever
someone says makes any sort of a small
comment about Chuck you know that the
fact that you're chinese-american and
whether they mean it as a racist remark
or not that we often sort of lack the
ability to just sort of take it lightly
and and and and turn it into a joke and
I wonder whether you think that at any
time in the near future we can laugh at
ourselves with that kind of self
confidence I laugh at myself all the
time let's laugh right now this is if
you've seen wedding banquet by Angley
that's a very very funny movie about
Chinese parents wanting their son to
find the ideal wife and all this
pressure for him to get married and of
course he's gay I mean this is to me
there were so many levels of humor the
difference between mainland Chinese and
Taiwan Chinese I do laugh at myself the
time I'm married to somebody's American
he thinks a lot of he would think there
are funny things about this and I think
we have to laugh ourselves and I and
that's what I start out by saying is we
by nature we are funny people I didn't
realize how funny my parents were until
I learned Chinese and I really
are really funny funny people now that
we don't have the language barrier to
worry about so much I can see just you
know this is I think we would just enjoy
life more number one I think people
would be able to enjoy us more number
two and I think it would be indicate a
sign that we aren't acting like victims
we're not desperate anymore we've
actually were at a completely different
level of assimilation now and there are
aspects to our existence which is you
know just are funny and they the
cross-cultural clashes I think I was
just looking at Eric's book earlier
today and there's some lovely poignant
moments which which also can because
seen as humorous about what is it like
to not know you know what we are I mean
in and I can't I mean I would like to do
that in film I think that's a great way
to to show Asians in a completely
different line I think it can't be done
right now as we speak I'm sorry I didn't
mean laugh at ourselves in that way I
think we all laugh at our parents we all
laugh at our friends I think I think
that's a common thing we do what I meant
was that in sort of a public way that
that you know for instance when someone
sort of issue it when someone makes a
certain comment about Chinese Americans
sometimes they might not mean it in a
derogatory way but often a lot of civil
rights groups that represent Chinese
Americans do take it as in a derogatory
way for instance various cartoons that
may not be meant as racist are often
taken as racist so I'm just wondering
from that kind of a perspective I I
don't mean sort of but this personal way
of laughing at each other or at our
parents or anything like I mean in a
sort of a public way though the way we
often a lot particularly often the most
outspoken Chinese Americans who who
always seem to say that they're standing
up for the rights of other Chinese
Americans
it seemed to be a lot seemed to take
comments from other racial groups a lot
more seriously than those racial groups
sometimes take themselves alright that's
what I meant I think oh I was trying to
just that by saying first attitudinally
we have to be laughing I mean it's and
not to be so touchy and sensitive I
personally feel that way and if somebody
you know I may be in the minority here
in that sense but if somebody's doesn't
know any better and uses like blacks
will refer to themselves as [ __ ] now
we don't yet refers to ourselves as
chinks because it sounds still too you
know ugly but at some point we may be
able to let it roll off our back because
we know we're not that anymore with all
the connotations that that word has and
I think it starts really with oneself
being being able to look around and
maybe publicly we won't be so touchy
anymore I would think that would be a
positive sign I think this is where let
me just add one point to that which is
yeah this is worth David Henry Hwang
would I think would have had very
interesting things to say because these
dynamics of language and humor are not
just unfolding in the abstract they
unfold in a societal context of power
and I think that you know you you raised
the example for one thing let me say I'm
all for laughing at ourselves and I'm
all for not being on a hair-trigger and
when it comes to comments or perceptions
about us as members of a minority group
but that said I think the the tensions
that we feel sometimes in these public
incidents reflects the very transitional
phase that Chinese Americans as a group
are in so that when you have something
like the cover of the National Review
magazine of a couple of years ago that
had a stereotypical caricature that of a
you know the first lady and the
president and the vice president and
with buckteeth slanted eyes and bamboo
hats on the one hand you certainly want
to be able to believe this is a country
where that can roll off our backs and my
first instinct was not outraged when I
saw that but upon seeing how for many
people it
just it wasn't humorous so much as it is
it just kind of confirmed a stereotype
about asian-americans when you begin to
see that begin to recognize that words
jokes images and the rest carry
different kind of moral and power
baggage now that doesn't mean that every
single time there is a caricature a joke
or anything like that that those of us
who are in the media or in in the pub in
public life generally you know ought to
declare nuclear war there's got to be
some sense of degree in some sense of
perspective about this but I think that
it's just as important you know because
we are in this transitional set stage to
make sure that those who don't get
whatever joke was intended know that
it's not particularly proper or right to
make derogatory comments or pass off
derogatory images of a group of people
defined by their race or ethnicity other
questions yes Alice
Justice asian-americans
talk about
suddenly they're seeing
why
are you very much
our recession
how here whether that's in fact
there
I think that's just an absolutely
important question I think that in the
immediate aftermath of the campaign
finance scandals there certainly was a
chilling effect on a lot of Asian
Americans and made a lot of Asian
Americans who were either already
involved in politics or thinking about
getting him more involved in politics
make them think twice and I think that
was a natural consequence of some of the
things that were circulating the media
and some of the you know as congressman
Salmons said alluded to in his talk
earlier today this painting with broad
brushes and this inability to
distinguish between Asians on the one
hand and asian-americans on the other
and so I think in the immediate
aftermath there was this perhaps a bit
of a chilling effect but what I've seen
to be honest with you and I think it's
borne out by a lot of the people in this
room is that since then there continues
to be that momentum toward that
generally upward trend I see it you know
among people at my own contemporaries
there's a real shift I think in this
generation of people who are willing to
go into straight politics for one thing
working on campaigns getting involved
working for politicians but also again
as I said earlier public life defined
more broadly whether it's you know as
Oscar can speak to the realm of
philanthropy and civic life and
community service there's a fellow named
Danny CEO who many of you probably know
of who is one of America's foremost
environmental leaders he's in his early
20s and he's Asian American and I think
that there are many more like him and
perhaps in you know less visible roles
but who are finding ways to get involved
in public life I think this circles back
to the whole question of role models
we're at a point right now when you look
at the political realm where there's
still you can count on one or two hands
the number of elected Asian American
officials nationwide that everybody in
the country has heard something about
when I first got involved in political
work you know certainly figures like Bob
Matsui longtime congressman from
California were just real inspirations
to me but this you know as iris said as
well when there's a
relative dearth of asian-american role
models in that field you search out
other role models as well and I think
that's something that is absolutely
critical critical for Asian Americans to
remember as they try to move into public
life in the public square which is that
you can find your role models and your
mentors anywhere you look
you can search out people who you
identify with perhaps not along the axis
of ethnicity but along the axis of
ideology or the axis of personal style
or the axis of whatever it may be that
there are a lot of ways in which we can
identify with people that aren't merely
restricted to identity as we've come to
understand it that's number one but
number two I think it's just absolutely
critical as well for this rising
generation to recognize that Alice as
you said these scandals that may have
these chilling effects that may slow the
momentum they may fade and they may pass
but that momentum doesn't rebuild of its
own accord it only rebuilds if
individual asian-americans one by one by
one by one choose to get involved and it
can be on a smallest local level it can
be on the most you know seemingly
inconsequential sorts of public affairs
but it's just developing those habits of
political association of being in public
and of making your voice heard that I
think are really crucial and I do think
that they are on the rise at least
within the younger cohort right now I
might add that sometimes it takes a
scandal like that to galvanize people
and say we will not let this be the
final word about asian-americans
participation in politics and let's now
have all the more reason to be involved
and I think perhaps that is what's
happening hopefully it is yes
thank you my name is Kay Elia I first
like to applaud the panelists and thank
the committee of 100 for hosting this
conference and as I look around the room
two things stand out there are two
generations the founders of the
committee 100 who made this possible and
also individuals who are the
beneficiaries and who are the the the
future of our community a couple
comments that were made in terms of role
models and in terms of mentors I happen
to work for a large pharmaceutical
company Pfizer and I'm very involved
with our diversity initiative our
internal diversity initiative and we
started out as a minority mentoring
initiative and mentorship in corporate
America is by far I think the most
critical aspect for for advancement and
my plea is as networking goes occurs at
this forum that the individuals who are
in a position to help reach out and
mentor the younger generation I'm
referring to the founders of the
committee 100 my plea is that to the
action step is the follow up of those
who are looking for mentors that if you
have exchanged cards in here for those
people who are in a position to to help
out please respond because without that
the energies that that have that are so
obvious in this room will go to naught
it's very difficult once we go back to
our respective careers to be lost and so
when when emails or letters or phone
calls occur it's just at something else
but if it comes out of this this
conference my hope is that we treasure
it because we all invested time in
coming here and a wonderful experience
and I and I look forward to a lot more
productive work as a result thank you
modern young into faith it talks about
this concludes our program I want to
thank all the those that made this
possible all the speakers all our
sponsors the committee members our
volunteers and our staff I hope you had
a good meeting